my channel is sponsored by hellofresh so
we will have an ad from them somewhere
in the middle of the video
good morning i have partly been living
kind of in shambles
um because i've been waiting for this
bookcase to arrive in my new place
because it hadn't arrived i just have
like all of these collectibles that i
haven't had anywhere to put so they're
kind of just like all over the floor or
wherever else i can fit them except for
these ones actually which i'm very
stoked about i was previously putting my
batman statues just wherever they would
fit so having like
i have distinct shelves now
if i come in and open this
i'm going to get
another shelf put in like here
i'm going to move the bat wing and i'm
going to hang him sideways um but i love
that like now i have themed shelves i
chose them based on how they look
together like this one's all colorful
this is for action figures
and then this one up here is everybody
who's like extra cartoony or goofy
looking i love it i'm gonna put another
batmobile that i have up there
and um yeah but this video is not about
batman this video is about everyone else
today i'm going to build a bookcase
and i'm going to be putting all of my
statues that are not a batman on the
bookshelf and i'm super excited about it
i'm very excited to have this done
it means i can also get rid of like a
lot of boxes that are currently just
sitting around
to safely hold
collectibles so
let's do it
okay
we built it uh i've jumped a few days
ahead at this point because i needed to
buy wall anchors and make sure that i
finally wall anchored the thing because
of course i am in california and i don't
want this to fall over once i put
all my beautiful collectibles on it i
have just amassed
every single collectible
that i have
and we do have unfortunately a couple of
breaks that i'm going to need to repair
but yes outside of the stuff that is uh
in my office
these are all the bits and pieces that
were just
chilling in um in different boxes that i
am going to put on this big beautiful
bookcase breaks um i expected but this
is the sword for this death stroke right
here
um this is the base
for the inside collector edition which
is snapped and dr manhattan here
one of his arms has come off um but this
is probably where they had originally
fixed it to the figure so i actually
think this one's probably gonna be an
especially easy fix also not keeping
this carpet down here this is gonna go
upstairs but i wanted to lay it down
just for everybody to chill on
for the purposes of putting the bookcase
together so yeah we're going to do our
repairs super quickly um
again something i expected when you're
moving and you have a lot of figures um
and there are some that i go in the
boxes for things break dr manhattan i
actually do have the box but he broke in
the box so i'm assuming that just wasn't
fixed to the figure super well i'm gonna
be a lot of unboxings as part of this
actually which is pretty cool
some of these i will be opening for the
first time too which is very exciting so
let's get to it oh also i do not know
where this freezer's head is
i mean i think it's probably amongst
this somewhere
but i don't know exactly where so
yep we'll figure it out
so first up i have two statues that are
going to be too tall for the shelves so
the decision is made easy
they are going to have to go on the top
that is the king of red lions and
vampire batman
the third one that's too tall to go
anywhere else is majora's mask that is
gonna have to go in the middle shelf
right here those decisions are very easy
um but he is in a box right now so we're
gonna have to unbox him
[Music]
i figured just to get through them i
might get through all of the unboxings
at this point i have already unboxed
kirby
um i had already done that one but we
have madarasu banjo-kazooie and ganon
puppet zelda
all from first ball figures also my
doctor manhattan is chilling like that
because uh
it seemed like the best way to keep his
arm in the correct position while he
continues to dry
[Music]
okay we are now
just about to open the single most
expensive
um almost
valuable uh collectible that i have ever
and probably will ever own
this is the crystal charmander from
daniel arsham um i do also have the
charizard card that he has um but i'm
actually not going to display that one
today because i cannot for the life of
me figure out how to
safely display it
this i haven't opened and i'm very very
excited to open
while also like terrified of the fact
that i own it in general
um i wish there was a better way for me
to display the camera maybe i didn't
move it down
it is time to talk about hello fresh get
mouth-watering seasonal recipes and
fresh pre-measured ingredients delivered
right to your door with hello fresh
america's number one milk it hello fresh
makes cooking at home fun easy and
affordable no matter what's going on in
the world everyone's gotta eat that's
why hellofresh is here to make eating
better easier no grocery stores no
stressful meal planning just everything
you need to prepare wholesome delicious
meals all delivered to your door i think
a lot of you watching my youtube channel
here probably know how busy i can be and
how difficult i sometimes find it to
even have a social life because i am
always working oftentimes that can
unfortunately lead to ordering takeout
or having some really bad food options
or not having a properly balanced diet
hello fresh can really really help out
by getting you a home-cooked meal on the
table every day which is a huge
accomplishment and they can help you out
with 50 weekly menu and market items to
choose from so you can think less about
what's for dinner and more about
achieving your goals plus every recipe
is packed with fresh produce sourced
directly from farmers there's also a
wide variety of quick and easy recipes
including 20 minute meals easy clean up
and low prep options which i am
definitely using it is a can't beat
value even at full price it's over 30
cheaper than grocery stores and with
this holiday deal it's time to try for
even less so use my link or go to
hellofresh.com and use code pog alana16
that is
p-o-g-a-l-a-n-a-h-16 for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts across
six hello fresh boxes plus free shipping
gifts include free appetizers free
desserts and free premium recipes
it's uh
it's pretty special um it'll probably
have gloves
inside of it as well i don't even know
that you're really supposed to display
these things out in the open um and
maybe i'll i'll get a
custom uh glass case for it this is cool
we've got a bunch of like
charmander stats
on this side here that's neat
it is all one piece
and it is
very heavy
and uh
oh my god
the
the chunks taken out of it
um it has real crystal
which is why this thing is worth
a lot of money truly fine art i love the
pose and his expression um
wow it's like i'm holding a baby
and yeah like i said i do have a
the charizard card which is the same
color as this is like pinkish color that
also has um the chunks taken out of it
with little crystals inside it um in a
box over there but
because it's basically a tablet i don't
want to just like sit it up right in
case it falls over so i need to find
some kind of like custom tablet stand to
lean it backwards on something so that i
have something to safely sit it on i
don't even want to take it out of the
box until i can do that that is
staying where it is but otherwise
we now have everything out of the box so
it's um
it's display time let's go
i put charmander up first just because i
wanted to take the gloves off so i guess
that's where he's staying but
um i think this is actually gonna be
kind of fun because i'm gonna sort
shelves based on like identity i guess
so let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
all right
that is everybody um
i have made some decisions and obviously
that cable is still there just i wanted
to charge everybody individually before
i um i'm going to hook them all up to
micro usbs permanently so they can
always be on
but until i get that done i just wanted
to charge everybody individually so
first things first obviously we moved
this batman right here
um off of this
particular shelf
um because all of these guys were too
tall so they have to go up the top
um just for the for the height
restriction and i also just felt like
the batman didn't suit the vibe
especially when you know i have that
batman corner around the corner i'll
figure out a way to integrate him in
there but i like
um the tops being all
uh nintendo properties i think that's
cool i do wish that i could have put
zelda on a different shelf because the
king of red lions is such a beautiful
statue
uh but height limit doesn't work so i
could potentially you know move a shelf
down um i could undo a shelf
and fit her in somewhere but it's not
too bad i figured i could also have
zelda over with banjo and kazooie but i
don't know i think it makes more sense
to have
zelda on zelda
majora's mask in the middle i think
looks awesome so this is the biggest
decision
i am uncomfortable with this being here
basically as soon as i put it there
i was like
nope i i'm already anxious about it
being there so i'm actually going to
move this one
and i had mentioned this right here is
the
box that has the charizard card in it um
those are gonna go in my bedroom just so
that i feel a little bit more
comfortable
i don't like having something above it i
i just yeah i don't like it so we are
going to move that um this right here i
have an unboxing of this from years ago
is also one of my most prized
possessions
um that i feel a little uncomfortable
having down here as well because this
was handmade for me um one of a kind
and it is breaking so i think that he is
also going to go
in the bedroom so i will clear this
shelf out this one looks freaking
chaotic but i really like it actually
this is obviously a nintendo shelf uh
these two also light up um and i will be
putting micro usbs in them as well to
make sure that they are constantly lit
up matarasu here with a tiny amaterasu
this one i find very funny we've got the
brain from psychonauts this is uh from
inside in kirby and then just this
little dog um i think i should probably
move him like the far cry dog i mean i
love this figure and i love the
character even if i wasn't huge into
that game
um but what a funny shelf it's so funny
to me to have like kirby next to this
like that's made of the same material as
actual sex dolls i just i like it a
little weird pink fleshy shelf this is
obviously a comic book shelf i think
this looks dope i had to do some posing
and rearranging to get everybody to fit
but i love it this year um the death
stranding baby and the bioshock figure
do also both light up but both of them
require batteries i think the death
straining figure probably still has
charge
it does
but there's no way to permanently plug
it in unfortunately um obviously we've
got the cyberpunk
lady in here and this one yeah it would
require battery changes which i'm not
really about and then i wanted to add
this to the shelf as well
um just because that's something that
was a
a limited edition special from e3 this
would be an animation shelf uh i've got
my dbz figures over here i have a lot
more of those in australia actually
and that lovely broly in the back and
then donatello the best ninja turtle and
uh mysterio from south park this is the
second thing that i'm going to change um
they can live here for now but because i
felt like it would look a lot cooler i'm
gonna figure out a way to hang all of
the masks
um all three of them i will find a way
to be able to display them probably on
top um right now i have two skateboards
that i want to hang up there that i
bought brackets for so that we can
suspend them up the top but
i think i could find a nice way to
display these guys around as well i'm
probably gonna have to have a custom
solution for each of them like the uh
darksiders mask obviously
that's mask there is gonna require
i don't know some
weird method to figure out how to hang
it but i will figure
something out halo shelf here obviously
um the hunter also didn't fit so i had
to remove
one of his little spires that i've just
put there for now um
which normally i would hate but i'm okay
with it because his statue is actually
broken anyway uh this is not my statue
ign let me take it with me when i left
kind of as a gift so even when it was at
ign when i first saw it it had pieces
missing um and was broken there's a bit
missing here and a couple of bits
missing off the back um and if i didn't
love that statue so much maybe that
would be cool for me to get rid of it
but i still love it i love the pose so
um i'm fine with taking something off of
it to make it fit there
it looks neat and then this right here
right now is obviously a mess um because
this is where the charger is i basically
just bought a dock that will have nine
usb outlets and i'll
i'll you know do all my cable management
and route them up the um
of the corners to get everybody
permanently charged i bought a bunch of
six foot
micro usb cables all chilling down here
this is like my hero's shelf kind of
obviously with mr x as well i feel like
uh because he's one of the few figures
that i have boxed um and i tend to keep
boxed that he's a good person to just
hide that power outlet um so obviously
this looks chaotic right now but yeah i
do need to buy some blue tac
because some of these figures will not
stand up by themselves unfortunately we
have this shelf here as well um is
my uh ronin geralt from sideshow and
this pogofit that i've had for ages and
a variant joker from playazkai i just
kind of liked the idea of having a shelf
that has
characters that don't exist these are
all obviously
variants of characters um different
styles of characters
and i don't have a whole lot of those
but i do like them so i'll probably
space these these guys out a little bit
nicer but that is the idea with them
gotcha matarasu's samus's gun there
um
so yeah
i'm gonna leave these guys down here for
now i think it'll take me a while to
figure out how to display them
but uh we can move the charizards right
now
all right there's a bit of a rearrange
got rid of the cables
and i decided to move the master chiefs
up because they just feel like they
deserve a bit of a higher spot so now
i'm just going to turn the lights off
and turn everything on just to see how
it looks it should be pretty cool so
devastatingly majora's mask and kobe do
not have enough charge
but man that matarasi flame is so cool
and then those are the waves for wind
waker so i think that just based on even
the way that this looks um i mean this
shelf will have two little lights but i
think i probably need to move the curvy
shelf
over here and swap that one over there
just because i want to spread the light
out a little bit
um so we're gonna do that too
but that we'll have to wait for another
day i'll probably post that on instagram
see how they all actually
look
with all the lights on when i've got all
those cables done it should be pretty
awesome thank you for watching everybody
i hope this video was uh at all
interesting i thought it would look cool
i guess i'll see what i edited
i still expect it to look cool very big
thank you to hellofresh for sponsoring
the channel that is it for me today
everyone if you'd like to see updates on
how it ends up turning out when i
get everything plugged in stay tuned